Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Früh ist's, die Vögel einzwitschern.
Ja
Sonne ist gerade eben erst durch den Nebel gebrochen.
Ja.
Ein unglaubliches Orange-Rot begrüßt uns.
Wahnsinn.
Romantik und das ist mitten im Studio, wo man eigentlich gar nicht richtig rausgucken kann,
Aber es ist einfach die Imagination. Es ist einfach das Bild, was man selbst im Kopf erzeugt, was entscheidend ist. Und deswegen hört man Podcast. Weil die so gehört werden, müssen wir welche machen.
So auch die fünfundvierzigste Ausgabe von.
Lockbuch Netzwerk.
Genau, so ist es. Dem Linus Neumann Podcast,
der uns immer das spannendste, aufregendste, wichtigste und überhaupt Lustigste der Woche präsentiert. Und äh an Schenkelklopfern war jetzt die Woche auch nicht arm.
Nee. Ist sie sowieso ja die, also wenn man,
man denkt, dass der im Winter immer so ist, alles ganz schlimm ist, aber in Wirklichkeit scheint ja überall nur die Sonne. Man sieht sie nur halt nicht wegen der Wolken, aber ähm wenn man dann so ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, passieren auch lustige Sachen. Während die Sonne da oben scheint.
Das stimmt, aber nicht jeder sieht die Sonne, deswegen müssen wir sie jetzt mal zeigen.
Ja
Bundesgerichtshof hat äh ein schönes Urteil gesprochenes Urteil, was äh kurz äh äh gefeiert wurde, als das Ende aller Abmahnungen. Das war, glaube ich, äh etwas zu äh zu früher Freude. Aber was war geschehen? Ähm,
Es fanden die eine Gruppierung von,
Urheberrechtsinhabern stellte fest, dass von einer bestimmten IP-Adresse im Internet Audiodateien geteilt werden,
und äh wie wir alle wissen, ist das ja nicht erlaubt. Äh auf Tauschbörsen, Audiodateien verfügbar zu machen.
Nö, weil wo will wer denn da hinkommen?
Tausendeinhundertsiebenundvierzig zum kostenlosen Herunterladen angeboten und dann haben sie also den üblichen Weg genommen von der Staatsanwaltschaft, den Inhaber der IP-Adresse bestimmen lassen,
und äh erstaunlicherweise dann sogar eine Hausdurchsuchung dort durchführen lassen,
und im Rahmen dieser Hausdurchsuchung wurde ein äh ein wohnungslos wurde dann ein Computer beschlagnahmt, auf dem waren
Programme installiert. Das Ganze hat jetzt zweitausendsieben stattgefunden, wenn ich das recht erinnere, diese Hausdurchsuchung und entsprechend
hießen da die falschjährigen Programme noch anders. Während man heute so oder so was nutzt, ja? Musste man damals noch Morphieus und,
Ich glaube, das ist so das so Kasar und so die Zeiten waren das, ja, das nutzt man.
Hazard siebenundneunzig. Es ist zweitausendsieben, es bittet dich.
Nee, nee, aber so genau, das war so nach Kazarkan, glaube ich, morphys, also morphis habe ich auch noch eine Zeit lang genutzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob zweitausendsieben, also habe ich ihn benutzt jetzt, ne, also quasi zum.
Ja gut, aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht ganz ausgeschlossen, dass es sich zweitausendsieben noch in aktiver Benutzung.
Der hatte das offensichtlich noch, der hatte den Vater. Das könnte ein interessante Theorie entfalten, weil der hatte den PC von seinem Vater bekommen. Also das war der gebrauchte PC von dem.
Sozusagen noch die Software, die die Vater damals noch im Krieg eingesetzt hat. Das waren noch Zeiten.
Damals. Geh mir weg mit den turnen Star. Das ist doch alles neumodischer Quatsch. Ähm.
Ähm bei ist auch die Download-Qualität besser. Klingt die Musik besser?
Das klickt auch nach Vinyl,
So, da also genau, das war, jetzt kommt nämlich der Witz, habe ich noch gar nicht erzählt. Ähm der Computer, den sie ja beschlagnahmt hat, gehörte einem dreizehnjährigen Jungen,
Sohn, glaube ich. Äh der den Computer zu seinem zwölften Geburtstag von seinem Vater bekommen hatte. So und jetzt ähm,
Entscheidender Punkt, der Junge ist ja dreizehn und damit gar nicht strafmündig und der hat auch nicht irgendwie ein paar tausend Euro, um irgendwie eine Abmahnung zu bezahlen, das heißt, den kann man nicht anmahnen
So, was machen was machen die Rechteinhaber? Gar nicht blöd, sagen, ah, na ja, auf dem Monitor konnte man ja sehen, wenn man den Computer angemacht hat, dass da das BER Share-Eikon auf dem Desktop liegt
und deswegen haben die Eltern ihre Aufsichtspflicht verletzt und deswegen mahnen wir jetzt die Eltern ab,
und möchten irgendwie ähm Schadensersatz haben und die Abmahnkosten und so weiter. Und die Eltern sagten, ja,
Pass auf, Unterlassungserklärung, diese strafbewehrte Unterlassungserklärung, die modifizieren wir und unterschreiben die, aber äh ihr kriegt von uns kein Geld, weil äh wir haben ja unserem Sohn gesagt, der soll das nicht machen.
Wir haben dem ja erklärt, dass das, dass man das nicht darf. So und dann ähm.
Weil sie jetzt, was was quasi dann vor Gericht verhandelt wurde, war, haften die Eltern jetzt für das äh für das Fehlverhalten ihres Kindes, weil,
oder obwohl sie das Kind zwar aufgeklärt hatten, aber weil sie es nicht regelmäßig kontrolliert haben. Und damit soll deswegen sollten die Eltern haftbar sein,
und ähm bei einem ersten Landgerichturteil wurden die Eltern auch tatsächlich dann wurde den Eltern diese Schuld zugesprochen, weil sie nicht ausreichend kontrolliert hätten und zwar ähm stellte das Landgericht den Anspruch an die Eltern,
monatliche Kontrollen des Computers vornehmen sollen,
Ähm sowie irgendwie eine Firewall installieren, die verhindert, dass das äh Kind äh an Falschharing da betreibt.
Mhm, da hilft ja auch eine Firewall extrem.
Na ja, kommt halt drauf an, wie viel du bereit bist, zu bezahlen, ne. Also, ich meine, wenn du irgendwie ein schönes äh äh DPI irgendwie da noch installierst, kriegst du das vielleicht.
Das gibt's bei Siemens schon für niedrige sechsstellige Beträge in dem Einstiegscup-Paket.
Nee, du kannst ähm,
du kannst natürlich irgendwie da sperren, ne? Also äh Administratorpasswort und äh einfach eine Firewall, die so eine Personal Firewall, die einfach allen Programmen außer denen, die du erlaubst, äh Internetzugang gibt so und dann,
Darf halt nur der Internetexplorer, Internetverbindungen herstellen. Ja, gut. Cocolores, also eine eine völlig.
Einfach albern.
Utopische Anforderungen an an Eltern eines eines zwölfjährigen Sohnes. Vor allem der hat der macht das doch in innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder weg. Das ist.
Ja, hat die tralala.
Ja, also und sagte, hat dann erstaunlicherweise auch der BGH ähm äh festgestellt und sagte, na ja, also,
wenn man ein dreizehnjähriges normal entwickeltes Kind darüber belehrt, warum es äh nicht illegal betreiben darf,
dann ist das eine ausreichende äh Handlung für Eltern,
und damit sind sie äh erstmal nicht verpflichtet, irgendwelche Internetanschluss äh Parameter zu sperren oder den Computer zu kontrollieren. Es sei denn, sie haben konkrete Anhaltspunkte,
Dann sind die Eltern haftbar, also wenn das Kind irgendwie, sage ich mal, regen Handel mit gebrannten CDs betreibt oder so, dann müssten die Eltern irgendwann sagen, sage mal,
downloadest du das,
oder so, aber grundsätzlich erstmal, äh solange die Eltern keine Anhaltspunkte haben und das Kind äh adäquat belehrt haben, äh können sie nicht haftbar gemacht werden.
Ist auch etwas schwierig.
Und damit wurde eine äh diese Entscheidung des Oberlandesgerichts Köln, in dem die Eltern äh den Eltern da die Schuld zugesprochen wurde äh oder die Haftbarkeit zugesprochen wurde, äh aufgehoben.
Woraufhin das Internet jubelte und Frau Lokte.
Jeder, der ein Kind unter dreizehn hat, kann betreiben.
Nee, aber ich meine gut, meine, was das jetzt betrifft, das wäre ja jetzt auch noch schöner, ja? Also wenn man jetzt tatsächlich,
Eltern haften für ihre Kinder mäßig, dass jetzt hier sozusagen auf jede äh digitale Aktivität im Internet erstrecken würde. Hallo, ja, ist einfach nicht realistisch. Ist auch ansonsten nicht äh nicht sehr realistisch.
Ob man jetzt von jedem Kind erwarten könnte, dass es immer das tut, was ihre Eltern sagen, ja. Hallo, was für eine Gesellschaft wären wir denn dann, wenn das mal so wäre, ja?
Naja, aber Moment, dafür haben wir dann die, die Rechteinhaber haben ja genau dafür geklagt, dass du eben deshalb kontrollieren musst, weil sie ja sagten, äh du bist weil du weil du ihm nicht darauf vertrauen kannst, dass dein Kind macht, was was du ihm sagst.
Ja, die wollen ja jetzt überhaupt nicht sonderlich äh zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis und äh meinten ja mit dem wir jetzt noch lange kein äh,
also die die Tore werden jetzt nicht final geöffnet worden, ja? Freut euch nicht zu früh und dann meinte der eine Vogel doch tatsächlich noch und ich weiß nicht, sagte er das irgendwie gegenüber der Presse oder sagt.
AfD gegenüber der.
Sagte er, man habe ja früher, früher habe ja auch mal eine Ohrfeige nicht geschadet.
Also er sagte, äh äh sah natürlich wieder die gesamte gesellschaftliche äh Dimension. Ich suche das, ich suche das,
Der Fall werfe ein grelles Licht darauf, dass für viele Eltern der Begriff Erziehungsaufgabe zu einem Fremdwort geworden sei, beklagte der Rechtsvertreter der Musikindustrie.
Während früher auch mal eine Ohrfeige nicht geschadet habe, würden Kinder heute,
an freier Leine laufen gelassen. Ärgerlich natürlich jetzt für Rechteinhaber, ne, dass man jetzt nicht wieder die äh ich glaube, wann wurde das offiziell? Die also das, ich glaube, vor zwanzig Jahren ungefähr.
Aus dem Verkehr gezogen worden, der irgendwie mit solchen Statements an die Öffentlichkeit tritt. Ich meine, geht.
Ahnung, aber ich ich denke, da wird demnächst mal das das äh das Jugendamt vorbei gebe.
Das ist ja jetzt mal das das geile Argument, ne? So, irgendwie, ihr müsst eure Kinder einfach mehr schlagen,
Das ist doch das, was das ist doch das, was uns die Musikindustrie jetzt hier quer ihres Rechtsvertreters äh mitteilen möchte, ja? Eltern müssen einfach ihre Kinder so lange schlagen, bis sie aufhören, Fallschirm zu betreiben. Das ist doch das, was er äh
eigentlich sagen würde, weil es habe ja früher auch nicht äh geschadet, ja. Er habe wahrscheinlich seine Kinder auch grün und blau geschlagen, bis einfach kein Bit mehr über die Leitung ging, oder?
So muss man das doch jetzt mal äh deuten,
Ich würde ja fast so weit gehen und sagen, auch bei der Musikindustrie würde vielleicht mal eine Ohrfeige nicht schaden,
Ja, weil solche Leute überhaupt äh,
äh von der Leine zu lassen, um jetzt mal hier ein Wortbild zu bleiben, so das ist einfach, das geht einfach mal überhaupt nicht, ne,
Penner,
Ihr seid echt Penner, ja? Das müsst ihr euch mal wirklich geben. Sollte irgendeiner von euch vögeln, hier zu hören? Dann sage ich euch jetzt einfach mal, dass ihr einfach mal scheiße seid. Euer ganzes Auftreten, eure ganze äh Gehabe in der Öffentlichkeit, das ist einfach nur noch,
peinlich. Und äh ihr schadet ihr schadet einfach. Das das muss man jetzt einfach mal sagen. Und eure Musik ist uns scheißegal,
ja? Es ist einfach ihr klimpert da irgendwie rum, okay.
Die klimpern ja noch nicht.
Tanzen dazu, aber ihr seid einfach unwichtig. Ihr seid einfach für die Zukunft dieses Planeten, seid ihr einfach unwichtig und ihr macht euch einfach mal echt zu dick,
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal gesagt haben, ey, Musik ist nicht das Wichtigste auf diesem Planeten. Kinder im Übrigen schon,
So, jetzt habe ich mich abgeregt.
Leider finde ich nirgendwo den Namen dieses Mensch.
Ja, den kriegen wir noch raus.
Büttner.
Regelverstößen sei man früher noch ganz anders vorgegangen, da hat auch mal eine Ohrfeige nicht geschaltet, sagte Büttner. So, wie heißt er denn jetzt mit Vornamen? So, das wäre jetzt mal interessant, weil äh der ist ja offensichtlich Herrmann Büttner,
So, Hermann Büttner, wollen wir mal schauen. Weil ich meine nämlich, dass also ich Doktor Hermann Büttner. Hm, verlinken wir mal.
Mhm.
Wer das denn ist, wenn wir das jetzt in, wenn wir den Richtigen haben.
Ja, hier gibt's auch einen Artikel da mit einem R, ne? Ein Anwalt.
Ein anderer. Doktor Hermann Büttner, ich kann mich erinnern, es es ist noch gar nicht so lange her, dass äh genau auch das mit der Ohrfeige, also die komplette körperliche
Züchtigung dann auch äh verboten wurde, ne. Also es war ja grundsätzlich schon, es gab irgendwie Kindesmisshandlungen. Es gab aber irgendwie im Prinzip die rechtliche Grauzone, dass Eltern ihren Kindern, das muss so
ungefähr zwanzig Jahre her sein, weil das war für mich damals äh ein Urteil, was mich schockierte, dass er jemals vorher erlaubt gewesen wäre, mich
zu schlagen. Ähm der ähm muss ungefähr zwanzig Jahre her sein, dass das äh verboten wurde
äh auch also sogar auch die äh die Ohrfeige, meine ich. Also ich glaube, man durfte irgendwie einen Klaps auf den Po, äh freundschaftlich oder so. Das das wäre dann noch unter Umständen durchgegangen bei dem nach dem nach dem.
Büttner und Baukelmann, Büttner Bindestrich Baukelmann DE, Rechtsanwälte bei dem Bundesgerichtshof.
Ja. So, müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir.
Barlachstraße Karlsruhe.
Mal gucken, ob der Kinder hat, weil dann würde ich da mal äh demnächst das Jugendamt vorbeischicken. Nur um mal zu gucken, ja? Nicht, dass da ähm,
ja. Also Spinner. Äh also aber was für eine Frustration, ja ich meine,
weit und dann irgendwie so, ja ähm wir wenn äh also wenn hier die die Rechte meines Mandanten nicht durch den Bundesgerichtshof äh gewahrt werden, dann müssen die Eltern eben ihre Kinder schlagen. Schlechter Verlierer.
Ja. Geboren neunzehnhundertvierzig in Nürnberg. Bankausbildung.
Aber das sieht man mal, ne, dass äh dass Menschen, die äh die die Feinde des freien Internets sind, auch so schlechte Menschen, ne. Also die sind das nicht nur im die sind auch so richtig schlechte Menschen. Die schlagen kleine Kinder.
Ja. Nicht nur aufm Papier, ja. Oder würden das zumindest gerne tun.
Also ganz großer Mann hier, toller bin ich froh, dass so jemand vom Bundesgerichtshof die Rechte von Mandanten vertritt. Da weiß man, was man hat. Ähm,
Was die die allgemeine Freude angeht, das ähm,
äh man jetzt jeder, der im im Besitzer eines eines Kindes unter vierzehn Jahren ist, jetzt äh Filesharing betreiben kann,
da bremst äh Thomas Stadler ein bisschen die Erwartungen. Denn was sich hier,
Also es gibt erstens die volle Urteilsbegründung noch nicht und was hier also es wird dann mal kommt halt darauf an, wie der BGH jetzt dieses Urteil begründet.
Und vor allem, wie eng der das umreißt. Ähm es kann also sehr gut sein,
dass es hier nur um die Haftungsfrage geht und da stehen also noch weitere Abmahnungs äh Urteile irgendwie in der äh sind noch offen, die da irgendwie abgearbeitet werden müssen. Und ähm jetzt werden wir, also es,
ist wahrscheinlich zu früh, jetzt zu sagen, cool, ich habe einen dreizehn, ein, ein, ein Kind mit Computer, äh das kann für mich Fallshering betreiben, das muss nur dicht halten, ne. Ähm also da da müssen wir halt sehen, es geht hier
anscheinend wirklich nur um Haftungsfragen. Es könnte zum Beispiel dann auch mal eine Rolle spielen bei anderen Dingen, die
Es gibt ja vielleicht auch Sachen, die Kinder mit Computern anrichten können, die wirklich vielleicht Relevanz haben.
Zum Beispiel äh was weiß ich äh äh eindringen in fremde Computersysteme oder so. Wie wie dann da, wie es da mit der Haftung der Eltern ist. So das scheint scheint eher in die Richtung zu gehen, als jetzt konkret äh und so.
Ja, so habe ich das auch verstanden.
Aber nach der aktuellen, nach der aktuellen Lage ist es also sehr, sind Eltern gut beraten, ihre Kinder
genau aufzuklären und ihnen zu sagen, dass sie es nicht machen dürfen, aber
vor allem nicht, wenn sie vierzehn sind, weil dann äh glaube ich, dann haften sie sind sie selber oder so. Ich weiß, ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob da die wann da die Grenze ist, ich glaube so ab vierzehn bist du strafmündig, ne? Dann könnte man.
Es gibt da so verschiedene äh Stufen.
Also vorsichtig, genau, also weil ich würde jetzt schätzen, mit vierzehn? Mit achtzehn.
Also so richtig strafmündig bist du dann auch erst ja und dann auch erst mit einundzwanzig sozusagen und dann kommt ja noch Jugendstrafrecht et cetera. Es gibt ja verschiedenste äh Abstufungen. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wann jetzt die eigentliche Mündigkeit wirklich,
beginnt.
Weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Uns mal wieder hier in schwieriges Terrain.
Also Eltern belehrt eure Kinder, dass sie das nicht machen sollen und äh.
Dann geht raus.
Dann geht rauf und wenn da irgendwo an, sagt den Kindern, dass sie keine Anhaltspunkte liefern dürfen, das solltet ihr euren Kindern sowieso sagen. Also das war das war so das, was was.
Genau. Das Bärshare sollte auf jeden Fall nicht direkt sichtbar sein.
Söhne, einfach das Eigenändern in Internet Explorer, da klickt nie jemand drauf und äh dann ist es.
Einfach mal ein atmen, Manuel zum Geburtstag schenken, so Hintergrundprozesse und so, geht schon was.
Das, ne? Das äh das geht ganz gut, ja.
Gut. Äh.
Ja, das ist jetzt nur so ein kleiner Lacher. Das nächste Thema.
Ja, was wollen die die Justizminister wollen Fahnen auf Facebook? Tun sie das nicht eh schon?
Ja ähm also das ich finde das ja eigentlich ganz geil. Ich finde das ganz geil. Jedes Mal, wenn irgendwie was wenn irgendwann durchdringt so,
Also irgendwann ist Facebook so oft in Nachrichten,
Irgendwie jemand denkt so, was ist eigentlich dieses Facebook? Ja, ist im Internet, da sind die Leute in einem virtuellen Raum. Und dann denken die sich so, oh krass, muss man gucken, ob wir da ähm äh irgendwie was machen können.
Ich erinnere mich immer wieder köstlich daran, wie Reiner Wendt, Vorsitzender der deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft, ähm prüfen wollte, ob man über Streetview Streife fahren kann.
Ja.
Ja? Das wollte der prüfen lassen. Kein Witz. Und weißt du, was der Obergag war? Es führte dann irgendwann.
Das ist mir doch mal super.
Es hat denn so, wir müssen prüfen, ob man darüber Streife fahren kann.
Ist doch super, dann wird die Polizei gefragt, sagen sie mal da in in der äh Hermannstraße, da ist irgendwie was passiert. Da ist ein.
Wir sind in fünf Minuten da.
In der Hermann-Büttnerstraße ist ein Kind geordnet worden. Können sie das mal überprüfen? So und dann ja nee, wir haben nachgeschaut, da war nichts, ja? Also da steht auch seit Tagen immer die gleichen Autos,
nix passiert.
Der tote Hund tote Hundezaun, da ist nichts mehr los,
Also und vor allem, ich finde das halt eben auch geil, ob also man stellt sich's vor, klicken die dann jedes Mal von der Wache los, klicken sich dann so vorne links, nee, da ist immer mehr Verkehr oder oben die Adresse eingeben kann.
Auf jeden Fall Reiner Wend.
Jetzt schauen sie doch mal am Barbarossaplatz vorbei. Ja, kleinen Moment, das lädt nicht so schnell. Ich muss hier noch erst um die Ecke.
Oder was machen die mit einer roten Ampel? Da machen die Blaulicht an und fahre dann drüber. Keine Ahnung. Also,
Polizei fährt Streife auf Facebook das Schöne war,
Das Schöne war, dass dann irgendwie, ich hatte das auf Netzpolitik berichtet, ich wusste nur, dass dann irgendwann in England tatsächlich, da gab's dann Verhaftungen. Mehrere Fälle von Verhaftungen, weil ähm,
quasi einmal irgendwelche Drogendealer, die immer an so einer Straße standen und da irgendwie gedealt haben, irgendwo in,
Ich glaube, das war in in Amerika. Die waren quasi dann von den Streetfood-Outdoor fotografiert worden und hatten sie eindeutig Beweisposition, konnten dann endlich verknackt werden,
Polizei, die monatelang da irgendwie und das andere war einer Familie, wurde ein äh Wohnwagen geklaut,
von ihrer vor ihrem Haus stand also ihr Wohnwagen und auf Streetview hat's dann irgendwann Street bekam, die Bilder waren ja auch zwei Jahre alt oder so. Aber dann stand halt die Karre mit Kennzeichen und,
und der Typ, der gerade ihren Wohnwagen klaut, haben die auch Streetview. Also das heißt, es gab Streetview-Fahndungen und es gab Streetview Based Verurteilungen, so. So und da ähm,
Ne, aber jedes Mal, wenn irgendwie so was Neues kommt.
Sagen wir mal, es gab es gab Verurteilung, weil Dinge durch ein Foto beobachtet worden sind so, ja.
So und ähm.
Ja auch schon mal vorgekommen sein.
Jetzt wollen die Justizminister der Länder wollen prüfen, ob und wie die Polizeifahndung über Facebook möglich ist. So und jetzt wollen sie wohl,
Was sie meinen ist wohl eher, dass sie sowas wie äh sie wollen Facebook-Freunde haben, denen sie dann sagen können, hier den suchen wir,
Ja, also was ja sowieso.
Facebook Freunde.
Keine Ahnung, sie.
Heißt, wenn du so ein Like kriegst von der Polizei, dann like.
Nee, du musst die Polizei liken, das macht ja keiner.
Was ich muss die Polizei leiten, damit sie mich einfangen oder was? Nee, ich dachte, die liken einfach alle, die.
Wann kriegt man denn von jemanden Statusmitteilungen? Wenn man den geliked.
Wenn du so, wenn du so eine Person findest, auf Facebook, da drunter steht irgendwie äh one hundred äh people like dis person und dann so Polizei äh Abteilung Hamburg, wo die Zeit tralala, ja, also wenn er sozusagen mehrere Fahndungs.
Nee, also was sie, glaube ich, meinen, ist, ähm also.
Die wollen dort die Fahndung organisieren, auf.
Die Polizei in Hannover bittet Internetnutzer seit längerem über einen eigenen Facebookauftritt, um Hinweise bei der Aufklärung von Verbrechen.
Sie wollen Steckbriefe aushängen.
Wollen eher so Steckbriefe. So und dann
meldete sich der Peter Schar und sagte, äh hält er nicht viel von. Peter Scharr, Datenschutzbeauftragter und sagte, naja, er ist da eher skeptisch und die Anforderungen für den Datenschutz werden in dem Fall sowieso schon mal, dass das ähm,
äh die eigentliche Fahndung über den Server der Polizei betrieben werden muss und höchstens auf Facebook dann die Links
verbreitet werden. Außerdem warnt er davor, dass dass da irgendwie so eine Löhnungsjustiz in dem in dem sozialen Netzwerk
entsteht und mit falschen Verdächtigungen und so dass das schnell mal viral wird oder so.
Da ist was dran.
Ja
Also ich weiß nicht, ich bin eine, bin mir eigentlich sicher, dass die die Facebook-Gesichtserkennung sowieso schon nutzen. Also wären sie ziemlich dämlich, wenn sie es nicht machen würden, um ähm um sage ich mal, bei halbwegs vernünftigen Bildern mal Anhaltspunkte zu bekommen,
Aber ähm man ist ja immer wieder überrascht, was äh was die Justiz und was die Polizei macht und was nicht. Hm,
Also keine Angst, sie wollen irgendwie über Facebook und jetzt gibt's natürlich sofort irgendwie Datenschutzprobleme oder so. Also das zeigt mal wieder, das kriegen sie sowieso nicht hin.
Wobei ich das jetzt generell nicht verwerflich äh äh finde, wenn wenn die Polizei auch in diesen Netzen präsent ist, also die Frage ist natürlich, wie wie sie das tun. Ganz klar,
grundsätzlich äh warum sollten die sich da raushalten?
Die halten sich da ja auch nicht raus.
Nö, also ich meine, sie fanden ja auch schon damit, in dem Moment, wo jemand halt äh irgendwas öffentlich macht, muss er natürlich damit äh rechnen, dass es gegen ihn verwendet werden kann,
In dem Moment, wo der berechtigte äh Verstöße gegen das Recht,
also unberechtigte Verstöße kriegen, dass Recht vorliegen, dann hat muss dem halt auch nachgegangen werden.
Ich habe ja ähm ich bin ja vor ziemlich genau etwas, also fast einem Jahr bin ich ja ähm zusammengeschlagen worden von einem mir Unbekannten. Vor einer äh Kneipe,
und ähm das war in einer relativ kleinen Stadt und ich habe daraufhin ähm diese Kneipe hatte eine Facebook-Seite,
und ich habe dann ein ähm mir einen Facebook-Account gemacht mit einer äh jungen Frau mit blonden Haaren
Schöne hübsche Frau als Profilbild und habe irgendwie randomly irgendwie äh Leute befreundet, weil die meisten ja eh automatisch auf äh Freund
ich bin dein Freund klicken und habe mir so eine face face Facebook-Identität gebastelt und bin dann auf der Facebook-Seite von dieser Kneipe
habe ich halt umgeschaut, wo ich Gesichter erkannt habe, die an dem Abend in der Kneipe waren und da habe ich so deren Freundeskreise wieder angeschaut und habe so denjenigen identifiziert, der mich äh zusammengeschlagen hat.
Habe ich, habe ich mit, habe ich mit dieser schönen Blondine bin ich seinen Facebook-Freund geworden, habe seinen kompletten Fotos alle runtergeladen und das der Polizei gegeben.
Wow, nicht schlecht. Ja.
Sechshundert Kilometer entfernte Stadt, so Arschloch.
Und ist das jetzt schon.
Ähm wie das läuft, so. Äh also man kann über Facebook fahren. Man braucht nur ein äh Foto von einer hübschen Blondine.
Äh auch strategisch sehr klug äh war es erstmal sich mit seinen Freunden zu befreunden,
und dann als allerletztes ihn, weil er dann gesehen hat, so, oh, guck mal, ah ja, schöne Blondine, die kennt ja schon meine ganzen Kumpels und.
Wow, wo ist denn das Futter hergehabt?
Ich hab Blondine, Blondine bei Google Image eingegeben.
Ja, also sollte.
Möglicherweise noch eine kleine Urheberrechtsverletz.
Ihr euch über eine schöne virtuelle Bekanntschaft in der letzten Zeit äh gefreut haben, auf Facebook, es könnte Linus sein.
Also wenn ihr mir die Nase brecht und das Bein, dann äh dann könnte es sein, dass ich euch auf Facebook suche, ja.
Dass ich euch auf Facebook angrabe. Okay, äh.
Also Privatdetektiv Linus äh.
Unterwegs, genau. Ja, äh, kommen wir äh zur Vergangenheit,
Und zur Zukunft, da gab es vor fünfundzwanzig Jahren mal ein äh Unternehmen namens Verein zur Förderung des öffentlichen, bewegten und unbewegten Datenverkehrs,
der sich dann so in der Folgezeit ganz gut gehalten hat und ähm vor allem auch so in den letzten Jahren doch erheblich,
an Aktivität äh zugenommen hat meiner Wahrnehmung nach und äh,
ist er allen in Erinnerung geblieben. Ich denke,
kann sagen, was zumindest hier so in unserem Umfeld der Name doch äh schon einer sehr etablierte Marke ist. Nichtsdestotrotz hat dieser Fürbot jetzt anlässlich seines fünfundzwanzigjährigen Geburtstags beschlossen, dass er seinen eigenen Namen nicht mag.
Schon vor einem halben Jahr oder so haben die das beschlossen, ne.
Wann sie's beschlossen haben, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Die halten wohl schon eine Weile äh dicht.
Suchten. Sie sucht.
Lange, lange Zeit ein und klagten schon häufiger, dass der Name ja irgendwie so schwierig sei. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was jetzt eigentlich daran so schwierig war an dem Namen.
Also was ich habe mich mal mit äh.
Bei der Republika, glaube ich, mit jemandem unterhalten, der es echt hätte wissen müssen und die Leute sprachen für teilweise sogar falsch aus. Die sagten dann, weil sie's irgendwie in der Zeitung gelesen hatten oder so, die sagten dann,
weil sie dachten, ist mit Computern, kann ja jetzt nicht irgendwie äh kann ja nicht irgendwie einfach Füllbrot heißen.
Forbert. Ah, ist natürlich die internationale Geschichte äh an der Stelle.
Ja, also.
Es noch gar nicht gesehen.
Kam doch glaube ich also war ja auch eine Persiflage so auf diese Post äh diese Post äh.
Vobat, so der.
Abkürzungen, die die bei der bei der Deutschen Post irgendwie alle waren, äh die und die der hat ja dann auch eine Mailbox betrieben schon. Also.
Fürth ist so ein bisschen so wie Fetap. Feta. Feta.
Fern, sprich Tischapparat.
Exakt. Na ja und andere, also so diese typische.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Despostartige Bezeichnungen für Dinge
ja? Dass man also so vollkommen absurde Wortmonster nimmt und daraus noch absurdere Abkürzungen zusammenklammbüßert. Und da das war sozusagen das, was damit äh reflektiert wurde.
Naja, also ich kann ja das Streben nach einem etwas griffigeren Namen verstehen. Jetzt allerdings wurde am Samstag dann äh,
Deckel dann gelüftet und tata! Jetzt heißt man und jetzt muss ich halt auch raten, ob ich das richtig ausspreche.
Ich weiß, wie man's richtig ausspricht. Ich äh ich habe noch mal noch eine PM bekommen und äh man spricht es deutsch aus.
Ja, digital, also was heißt deutsch? Das ist nicht deutsch. Also es ist schon, es ist deutsch, aber es ist ja eigentlich Französisch. Also, ich sage, es heißt digital Courage.
Oder Digitalcourage.
Ja, was ist denn jetzt die offizielle Bezeichnung? Du hast es hier übrigens gerade mit einem großen D hingeschrieben. Ich hab's bisher immer nur mit einem kleinen D gesehen. Was mich jetzt nochmal besonders verwirrt hat, weil wenn man jetzt betonen möchte, dass es Deutsch ausgesprochen wird oder deutscher
Begriff angenommen wird, dann,
ähm warum schreibt man's dann klein? Ja, weil damit äh forciert man ja quasi äh meiner Meinung nach, dass man's dann Englisch ausspricht, auch wenn's dann wiederum bricht, dass es ein Wort ist.
Ja und das Problem ist, wenn man's englisch jetzt interpretiert, dann ist, dann passt es nicht wirklich. Also ist nicht unbedingt das, was was äh man jetzt mit dem assoziieren würde im Sinne von äh
Also Mut zum Digitalen, also natürlich hat der für Mut zum digitalen, aber er ist ja hat ja durchaus einen Fokus beim äh beim Datenschutz
Bei dem Bürgerrechten und so was wie so würde bei mir jetzt eher so Assoziationen für so eine äh libertäre
mag lieber digital Sparkaria,
Position sehen. Also wenn man so sagt zum Mut, mehr digital wagen,
dann würde ich nicht unbedingt daran denken, dass der Füllbund eben auch sehr stark vor bestimmten äh also.
Na gut, Courage heißt ja, dass man, dass man äh die Fähigkeit hat oder den Mut hat, etwas zu tun, was eigentlich Angst macht.
Ich muss auch sagen, das Wort digital ist ja nun auch sehr
inflationär in Verwendung schon seit längerer Zeit. Ich akzeptiere, dass wir vom digitalen Zeitalter äh sprechen und das ist ja ein gewisser Hinsicht auch nicht falsch,
ja auch jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass ein neuer Verein in dieser Netzpolitischen Landschaft auftaucht, der halt mit digital anfängt,
Gibt es ja dann auch noch die digitale Gesellschaft, der man,
auch sozusagen, wo man auch drüber nachdenken kann, ob jetzt digital das Richtige, der richtige Präfix ist, ja?
Also es ist mir schon klar, worauf es sich bezieht bei digitaler Gesellschaft, ist es
doppelt klar, weil ja auch das zweite Wort explizit eben diesen Bogen aufspannt und sagt, okay, digitales Zeitalter, digitale Gesellschaft, we are all in the together. Digital Courage wiederum bezieht sich dann etwas indirekter da drauf und man,
könnte dem Ganzen ja jetzt auch
rein sprachlich mal äh hinterhergehen und sagen, okay, ja, was äh was macht die Courage, wann wird die Courage digital?
Ja, also gut. Auch das Wort Zivilcourage ist ja so ein bisschen äh merkwürdig in der Hinsicht.
Man schreibt uns mit diesem Namen wollen wir fortsetzen, was wir vor einem Vierteljahrhundert begonnen haben, uns für eine lebenswerte Welt im digitalen Zeitalter einzusetzen.
Bewusst
verknüpft Digitalcourage, da mal dabei an Zivilcourage an, denn das ist es, was eine lebenswerte Gesellschaft auch im Netz und im digitalen Wandel braucht. Menschen, die wie Sie und wir
couragiert teilnehmen am politischen Geschehen und die Dinge zum Besseren wenden wollen. Mit Digitalcourage
stehen wir weiterhin für die selben wichtigen Inhalte, Bürgerrechte verteidigen, Datenschutz stärken und das digitale Zeitalter lebenswert gestalten.
Tja,
Also ich verstehe ihre Motivation. Ich verstehe auch, wie sie äh dadrüber denken. Allerdings habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, ob der Viabilität dieses Begriffs. Ja, also wenn du sagst, ich bin jetzt beim Fürbot,
ja, vorbei.
Karriere vorbei oder.
Nein, dann ist, nein, dann ist vorbei, weil es ist nicht ganz richtig. Also dann ist das klar. Ja? So,
Ich bin jetzt bei der Digitalcourage,
Wir kommen mit der Digitalcourage, die digital Courage veranstaltet. Also.
Ich glaube.
Einen Seite versucht es ein ganz normales Wort zu sein, was irgendwie so einen menschlichen Zustand
beschreibt oder so eine menschliche Motivation beschreibt. Auf der anderen Seite soll es als Name für eine Organisation funktionieren. Und ich weiß gar nicht, kenne ich überhaupt irgendwelche anderen Beispiele, wo das so ist?
Also für mich ist das eher ein Wort für den Untertitel.
Ich du ich glaube auch, also ich glaube nicht, dass der seinen Namen loswerden wird.
Na das glaube ich nämlich auch.
Ist der.
Das macht jetzt dieser Name nicht einfacher.
Richtig. Ich glaube aber, dass sie ähm oder was.
Ich denke ja, dass äh eines der eine der Herausforderungen auf jeden Fall ist, gerade in den in den,
äh sage ich mal, Kämpfen der Internetaktivisten, die jetzt noch kommen werden, dass du äh vor allem,
nicht in eine konservative Rolle gedrängt wirst,
Ja, das ist äh PR mäßig das, was jetzt die ähm sage ich mal, die die Firmen mit ihrem Netzneutralitätskram und so weiter versuchen, die äh die ähm die Gruppierungen, die
ähm,
sage ich mal, sich gegen diese äh Netzneutralitätsverletzenden Angebote wenden, in so eine verstaubte äh ähm wertkonservative Position zu drücken,
So und wenn du dann, wenn du auftrittst als jemand und sagst, du heißt und dann hast du noch dieses Gelb und diese gesamte Postverarschung äh da mit drin, die die im Prinzip seit
auch jetzt fünfzehn Jahren nicht mehr zutreffend ist, weil die, weil die, weil die Deutsche Post das das Netz nicht mehr unterhält, sondern die Telekom, ja, dann ähm,
Läufst du quasi Gefahr irgendwie,
in die Falle zu laufen, dass der, der, der rhetorische Gegner dich als als äh überholt und konservativ und antiquiert dastehen lassen kann. Und ich denke, dass das die Gefahr ist, die der Füllboot äh auch vermeiden möchte
Und wenn man sagt, äh wie dem äh widersprechen.
Widerspricht so und so Sprecher des des Bündnis, des Vereins Digitalcourage äh spricht sich gegen diese Modelle aus, ist das besser als wenn da irgendwie steht so und so vom Füllboot,
fünfundzwanzig Jahren in Bielefeld irgendwie gegen alles. Ähm so dann steht das einfach ähm weißt du,
Verstehst du was ich meine? Also einfach ein positiveren äh nach vorne gerichterteren äh Beiklang dem Namen geben. Und das ist, denke ich, das, was sie versuchen und was sie eigentlich mit dem Namen auch hinkriegen, solange sie keiner Digitalcorsage nennt.
Oder Courtage.
Digitalcourtage.
Ja. Also ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht ähm verwitzeln hier. Ich habe nur so ein bisschen meine meine Zweifel. Jetzt wenn du sagst,
Verein, Digitalcourage, so in dem Zusammenhang passt es besser oder vielleicht wäre auch Projekt digital, Courage oder so ganz gut, aber ist einfach, es geht einfach nicht locker von der Zunge. Das kann man nicht sagen.
Aber vielleicht ändert sich das ja in den nächsten fünfundzwanzig Jahren. Kann ja sein.
Genau, wir wünschen natürlich Rena und äh viel Erfolg in den nächsten fünfundzwanzig Jahren.
Ja, nicht nur den beiden, sondern äh Laden ist ja nun definitiv größer als die beiden.
Aber die beiden haben's gaben den gegründet und äh,
Natürlich wäre, also es unterzeichnet in der in der in der PM unterzeichnet noch mit Lars Freitag, aber das Team ist natürlich insgesamt größer. Bei den Dreien insbesondere,
wünschen wir äh danken wir für die fünfundzwanzig Jahre, wünschen ihnen äh großen Erfolg in den nächsten fünfundzwanzig Jahren.
Genau und wer sich für die.
Unter dem gleichen Namen oder dem alten Namen.
Genau und wer sich so für die ersten ähm nah, die ersten zweiundzwanzig Jahre des Verburts äh interessiert, dann kann ich an der Stelle auch nochmal an CAE hundertvierzig äh erinnern, wo ich mit Trainer und Paddeln gesprochen habe, eben genau über den,
Und wo, glaube ich, viele so von diesen Hintergründen und warum das alles so ist, äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir euch den Namen selber auch,
gekommen waren, ja.
Ich erinnere mich an die Folge.
Mhm. Ja.
So
So, dann gab's noch eine kleine Veranstaltung hier in Berlin. Die Spacker mit den Spackos.
Immer so verächtlich von Konstanz zu kurz äh bezeichnet wurden und sich dann äh stolz, dass den Namen an die Brust hefteten.
Es war auf der Abschlussveranstaltung des siebenundzwanzig C3,
Kurz sagte äh nicht irgendwie von den Post Privacy Spacken sprach,
und kurz darauf ähm gründete sich dann die Datenschutz kritische Spageria,
ähm eine Gruppierung von äh Leuten, die sich für Post Privacy,
eine Welt ohne Privatsphäre oder eine das Experiment einer Welt mit immer weniger Privatsphäre im digitalen Zeitalter interessierten,
oder auch dafür stark machen wollten, also Kritik an Datenschutz äh Gesetz geübt haben und aber hauptsächlich auch
sag ich mal Befürchtungen die Menschen irgendwie hatten bezüglich ihre eigenen Daten ja in mal unter die Lupe genommen haben,
und ähm es kam dann beim achtundzwanzig C drei zu dem.
Konflikt, dass von keinem keiner dieser Personen
einen Vortrag angenommen wurde oder kein, keiner der Vorträge zu diesem zum Thema Post Privacy äh angenommen wurde bei in das in das Kongressprogramm,
was dann äh Anlass gab zu der äh zu der ähm,
Überlegung, dass der dass das Content-Team oder gar der CC sich gegen,
die Sparkaria vielleicht verschworen hätte oder so. Und,
Ich weiß, dass damals die relativ klare Ansage des ähm Content-Teams war, ja, passt auf
ihr was Neues zu erzählen habt, könnt ihr äh sehr gerne kommen, aber wir haben bei euren Einreichungen nicht festgestellt, dass sie eine ähm sachliche oder inhaltliche Ergänzung darstellen zu dem, was sie hier schon mal erzählt haben
und deswegen geben wir da anderen Vorträgen den Vorzug,
Daraufhin gründete hielt die Spaghea im letzten Jahr zeitgleich mit dem mit dem CCC-Kongress in Laufnähe
ihren ihre Sparkariade ab. Die Spagheriard mit der Nummer null,
Und da ich damals äh auf Krücken lief, weil ich gerade zusammengeschlagen worden war, ihr kennt das,
ähm bin ich da, konnte ich da nicht rübergehen. Weil es war für mich zu weit. Alle anderen konnten konnten zwischen gehen. Ich hab's, äh, mir was, mir ging's nicht. Für mich ging's nicht.
Waren schon ein paar Meter. Du bist ja eh schon zu viel gelaufen.
Ich bin da zu viel, gelaufen, ja. Ja. Ähm und dann ähm,
Haben Sie die, haben Sie sich gehalten, so und jetzt wurde dieses Jahr wieder eine gehalten, nämlich am, am vergangenen Wochenende und äh es richtete, es lud also die Datenschutzkritische Sparkaria ein in die Seaways in Berlin
und äh titelte die Veranstaltung,
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, öffentliche Daten nützen. Was ähm ja ein Bezug ist auf die HK-Ethik,
Wer hat von wem stammt der Ausspruch? Ist das wahr Holland?
Ja, ich denke.
Private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nützen.
Ja, das ist so quasi weiß äh und Umfeld Ergänzung der klassischen Hackerethik,
dieses Mülle nicht in anderer Leute Daten herum und öffentliche Daten nützen, private Daten schützen. Das ist so quasi diese CC-Note oben auf diesen Hacker-Ethik äh Zuckerguss ähm den halt mal äh der,
Steven Levi in dem Buch Hackers, Heroes of Acomputer Revolution äh abgegeben hat, seine Beobachtung der ähm,
entstehenden Hackerszene aus den Sechziger, Siebziger und Achtzigerjahren. Also diese drei Phasen, nämlich diese Uhrhacker am MIT, dann die ähm,
Hardware-Hacking, äh Bewegung der Siebziger, so ist die Frostenjagd et cetera, Apple und diese ganzen anderen Entwicklungen, die es damals gab und,
in den achtziger Jahren eben die auf den Homecomputern dann entstehende frühe Spieleszene,
So und das war dann sozusagen seine Summe. Das wurde dann eigentlich von der Hackaszene weltweit begeistert äh angenommen, eben auch vom Club Plus eben diese Ergänzung. Und diese öffentliche Daten nützen, das ist hier quasi das, was eben betont werden sollte. Im Sinne von, ja, wir wollen jetzt diese Debatte,
Äh nicht immer nur führen im Sinne von, was können wir alles verhindern, sondern wir wollen eben auch so eine Pro Sache machen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann auch diesen.
Diese Motivation kann ich gut verstehen,
Ja, weil das ist schon so, dass obwohl der Club aber eben auch jetzt nicht nur der Club, auch die ganze Szene, ja, et cetera und so weiter. Also man redet eben viel über die Risiken,
und man redet eigentlich selten über die Chancen,
Und das, obwohl man sich eigentlich auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, Chancen und Risiken einer äh elektronischen Welt.
Ausloten. Das kann man natürlich argumentieren, ja klar, aber es gibt ja hier so viel äh Gegenwind von Idiotie, ja?
Die im wesentlichen versucht da ihre Chancen dahingehend auszuluchten um einfach andere Leute Risiken nach oben zu treiben. Da ist natürlich auch was dran,
Trotzdem finde ich.
Begibt man sich einfach zu ungern und zu selten eben auch in so eine Chancendiskussion. Es wird dann immer gerne beklagt, wie unmodern äh dann doch wieder alles sei und
nicht wahr und die Internetversorgung und pipapo et cetera,
die ja wäre sie besser, mehr Chancen erzeugen könnte. Sowas wird eben schon gerne gemacht, aber sagen wir mal, auf so einer,
wirklichen Ebene, wo man sagt, auch das moderne Leben der Öffentlichkeit kann unter Umständen eine Chance darstellen, ja. Das ist etwas, was eben ja verpönt ist. Und ich denke, an der Stelle gibt's auch diese,
skurrile Bruchlinie, die da äh dieser netzaffin,
Gesellschaft äh existiert. Und die macht sich halt da irgendwie ganz gut fest. Nun kann man eben sagen, so viel ist da jetzt auch nicht bei rausgekommen. Also ich fand jetzt, ich habe jetzt nicht so viel, ich weiß nicht, wie viel hast du alle Veranstaltungen,
gesehen. Ich,
konnte er auch erst am Nachmittag dazu stoßen, dann vielen dummerweise auch noch gleich zwei. Äh Vorträge am Ende aus, aus Krankheitsgründen.
Genau, also es war man kann,
Man muss den den ersten Tag kann man äh resümieren. Äh Gregor Seelag, der ja auch äh bei uns schon zu Gast war. Ähm hat einen Vortrag gehalten, den den ich den ich schon kannte, der äh sehr interessant ist, wo er so in jedem Jahr so ein bisschen
also
politische Bewegung, politische Konfliktfelder, das so ausdrückt und quasi die Spagheriard direkt aus den achtundsechziger äh die Sparkaria direkt aus den Achtundsechzigern her äh äh herleitet. Äh sehr amüsant, aber auch eben mit Seelachsschirm
Verständnis zu verstehen und dann gab's einen Vortrag von den hab ich dann nicht gesehen,
von jemanden, der irgendwie seinen Computer so programmiert hat, dass er andauernd ein Foto von ihm macht in Unregelmäßigen Abständen das hochlädt.
Also sein iPhone.
Nee, seinen seinen Laptop wohl, aber äh und es gab auch noch einen mitm iPhone, so. Also so,
Das waren also Menschen, die die äh das irgendwie für notwendig achten, äh sich selber zu fotografieren, das irgendwie als postprivates Experiment äh dann so so anerkennen und ihm ihr eigenes Panoptikum bauen oder was so. Ja, schöne Sache.
So ein Netz exhibitionismus.
Genau, also sie sind offensichtlich also ich kann mir da den den Witz nicht verkneifen, so wo, also ich sehe einfach wenig Nutzen für die Öffentlichkeit,
auf den Titel der Veranstaltung angesprochen, ich sehe wenig Nutzen für die Öffentlichkeit, wenn irgendwelche Menschen äh meinen, dass sie, dass sie der Gesellschaft irgendwie einen Beitrag bieten, dadurch, dass sie äh das Bild, das Internet mit Bildern von sich zuhauen. Ähm,
Das wäre jetzt so und so ging's dann, glaube ich, auch weiter. Dann dann kam die Birgit heißt die, glaube ich, ne. Richlewski ist richtig ausgesprochen.
Ist richtig ausgesprochen. Kann ich dir gerade nicht sicher äh.
Auf Twitter äh unter Unterstrich Ria Unterstrich äh ja genau, er Y A, also Unterstrich äh Y,
Unterstrich. Ähm dir mehrfach schon irgendwie ähm Probleme hatte mit den mit der Presse, weil sie über äh ihr Sexualleben twitterte,
gleichzeitig aber ähm in einem Parlament sitzt, nicht wahr?
Rütleski.
Rütleski, siehst du, Mist. So, in welchem Parlament sitzt die? Jetzt bin ich jetzt auch grade äh durcheinander. Äh,
Ja, in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Ähm,
So und die äh twitterte, glaube ich, vor einiger Zeit schon mal über irgendein Problem ähm mit einem gerissenen Kondom und an welchen Körperstellen man sie lecken könnte, wenn man drüber twittert und an welchen man sie denken kann, wenn man nicht drüber twittert und so,
ähm da hatte dann der äh,
Bild-Zeitung äh Interesse daran gefunden und und nahm die Frau dann im Prinzip auseinander mit äh Sex, Twitterer, äh erregt den den Landtag und äh ja, haben also ihr, glaube ich, da,
haben ihr da relativ übel mitgespielt. Letztendlich dann noch, glaube ich, äh jetzt vor wenigen Tagen ihre Fraktion, die ihr dann.
Haben sich für die Steilvorlage bedankt.
Haben sich dafür,
haben sich dafür äh bedankt, ja, also man sie hat einen einen Vortrag darüber gehalten, was da ihre eigenen Erfahrungen damit sind. Jetzt ähm stellt sich also ist natürlich auch interessant, also ist eine,
im Prinzip dieser Frau wird aufgrund ihrer,
des öffentlichen Interesses, was auf ihr lastet, quasi äh hat sie eine Einschränkung ihrer ihrer Freiheit äh über Sex zu twittern unter einem Account mit mehreren tausend Followern und ähm,
dass wir zu einem Politikum, wo sich dann am Ende sogar die Fraktion äh,
gezwungen, sieht irgendwie eine Pressemitteilung zu machen, wo sie sich von ihr distanzieren. Ähm das ist ähm also,
sicherlich ein Phänomen, was ich finde, wo es sehr interessant ist, sich darüber zu unterhalten. Und was nicht so einfach äh damit abzuhaken, ist zu sagen, okay, vielleicht ist es wirklich nicht besonders schlau von der Frau, äh das zu machen, vor allem wiederholt.
Ja, man könnte aber natürlich das auch zum Anlass nehmen, sich äh da mal eine Kritik an der Gesellschaft zu entwickeln im Umgang mit solchen Themen, mit der Privatsphäre von Personen generell.
Ähm und in diesem Zusammenhang finde ich nämlich solche Vorträge oder denke ich, wenn man das unter dem Gesichtspunkt sieht, war das äh ähm das Programm der Spaghearde oder die Vorträge, die da auch gehalten wurden, eigentlich ziemlich interessant.
Nämlich als so eine so eine Art Soziologie, sozialpsychologen, experimentieren, äh Philosophiegipfel,
über die Zukunft der Gesellschaft mit weniger Privatsphäre oder so, aber mit dem Anspruch eine mit einem politischen Anspruch,
Kann ich diese Veranstaltung nach dem, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, kann ich eigentlich die Gruppe nicht ernst nehmen.
Und da würde ich halt also mein persönlicher Rat wäre äh Titel der Veranstaltung nächstes Mal ein bisschen äh strategischer wählen,
Und nicht irgendwie so eine, so einen politischen Seitenhieb dann auch noch auf den CCC bringen, der eigentlich völlig unnütz ist. Und vielleicht mal dieses Datenschutzkritik rausnehmen,
Weil auch diese die Vorträge, die da gehalten wurden, hatten relativ wenig mit Datenschutz zu tun. Also da waren jetzt keine Menschen, die durch Datenschutz, durch das Datenschutzgesetz
an dem Ausleben ihres ihrer ihrer Wünsche gehindert werden, ja? Und das, was ich jetzt mir, was ich ja erwartet hatte, ich hatte ja in der Ankündigung, hast du ein bisschen gesagt, ich hatte erwartet, dass jetzt ein,
viel über die Macht aggregierter Daten und Datenanalysen gesprochen wird, dass man sagt, hier ähm
Wir können äh also einer der Vorträge, die ausgefallen sind, der sollte sich zum Beispiel damit befassen, dass äh äh.
Das im Prinzip der so 'n Amazon Kindle ja die Möglichkeit bietet Stellen im Buch zu markieren,
und das ist quasi, wenn man das jetzt aggregiert von allen hat, dieses Buch auf dem Kindel lesen, dann kriegt man quasi Daten darüber, wie die Leute die Bücher lesen und welche Stellen sie wichtig finden und so. Und das ist ja
kann ja, es bietet ein komplett neues Forschungsfeld im Prinzip
in der in der Literaturwissenschaft, in der Psychologie, für ganz viele Wissenschaften bietet das ein äh bitte, dass
Und das nur ein kleines Beispiel. Einer der Vorträge, die leider ausgefallen sind. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ähm,
da da stellt sich dann das gesellschaftliche Problem und nur darum geht's ja im Datenschutz, dass diese Daten eben nicht,
der Forschung zu zur Verfügung stünden, sondern eben Amazon und die nicht bereit sind, diese Daten zu teilen,
Ja, da da kommt man dann in den in dieses politische Feld, in dem sich dann die Datenschützer bewegen. Die sagen, äh und es gibt Datenschutz und Open Data, das sind Dinge, die sich überhaupt nicht widersprechen, ja? Also quasi dieses öffentliche Datennützen,
Äh und also da das ist ja eine das ist ja was, was wo die Spagheria den den tradierten CCC-Position überhaupt nicht gegenüber steht
Und deswegen habe ich mich gewundert, warum sie ihre äh ihre gesamte Ankündigung so so konfrontativ machen.
Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht so bösartig gemeint, wie ich das als CCC-Mitglied dann äh auffasse, aber ähm.
Glaube ich jetzt auch nicht, dass das irgendwie böse gemeint ist. Ich glaube, das ist einfach eher so ein bisschen so ein so ein Augen äh zwinkern, dass man da
jetzt erstmal auch nicht mehr so sehr viel Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, ob der Name jetzt noch groß passt oder nicht, sondern man ist eigentlich da vielleicht auch selber noch ein bisschen
auf dem Weg irgendwas zu finden, weil irgendwas versucht sich da ja schon Ausdruck zu verschaffen. Und ich würde mal sagen, es ist im Wesentlichen einfach dieser ähm,
zwischen dem privaten und dem Öffentlichen, was bisher einfach immer sehr stark getrennt war
Ja, also alles, was irgendwie nicht öffentlich ist, ist privat, alles was privat ist, ist nicht öffentlich. Und das reist irgendwie. Also es ist äh es lässt sich teilweise gar nicht mehr,
herstellen, wenn man's wollte, ja? Es wird einem teilweise nicht zugestanden, wenn man's will, obwohl man's will,
und äh,
teilweise vermischt es sich für viele Leute auch in einem Maße, wo man selber auch schon gar nicht mehr so richtig die Möglichkeit hat, dazu trennen. So ein bisschen so ähnlich wie das bei mir zum Beispiel schon ist, mit meinem Verhältnis zwischen dem privaten,
und dem, wie nennt man das, dem Business? Ja, also so äh Hobby und Beruf, ja, so,
Habe ich noch nie so richtig auseinanderhalten können und.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich so im Café sitze und irgendwie mir dann meinen Rechner habe und ich tippe irgendwas energisch, dann kommen so Leute auf mich zu und sagen, ach du arbeitest noch.
Weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, ja? Also wie, was arbeiten wo, ja, wo, wovon redet ihr, weil weil ich dann auf einmal sozusagen mit so einer gesellschaftlichen,
Tradition, ja,
das so stark zu trennen, konfrontiert bin, die überhaupt gar nicht mehr passt, wo wo ich jetzt auch nicht, was weiß ich, wo ich jetzt nicht in so einen Aktivismus verfalle und sage, so nein, ihr müsst das jetzt alle äh,
so machen wie ich, das erreicht der Punkt, das war will das halt auch so machen, kann ich ja auch, nur bei diesem privat, politischen wird's halt schwierig, ich meine die Rühja zum Beispiel hat ja dann in ihrem Vortrag dieses Beispiel gebracht, die kennen jetzt ihre ganzen Tweets, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht jetzt also die Party, die du erwähnt hast, kannte ich jetzt noch gar nicht,
Aber so dieses mit dem gerissenen Kondom, leider da ging's ja letzten Endes um hier, ich habe einen HIV-Test gemacht, der ist irgendwie negativ, alles ist gut. Ja, und sie hat es einfach bewusst äh
Das kann man jetzt verurteilen, das ist irgendwie unklug war und, und, und, und, und, und im Kontext, dass sie jetzt im Landtag sitzt, et cetera, also es mag auch alles sein, dass es unklug ist, ja, wenn man das jetzt aus so einer Partei,
politischen äh strategischen Sicht heraus äh bewertet, ihr ihre Intentionsmiss, was sie sagte, war ja äh ich möchte,
Habe überlegt, ob das jetzt irgendwie eine öffentliche Nachricht ist oder nicht. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich's eben auch dieses Private auch öffentlich mache.
Könnte ich ja unter Umständen auch,
Erzielen im Sinne von, dass äh Leute auf dieses Thema aufmerksam werden. Und das ist sozusagen nicht mehr so anrüchig ist, über so etwas zu reden, ja, was nämlich gemeinhin in die Privatheit verdrängt wird, aber ihrer Meinung nach,
nichts zu suchen hat. Oder da schon was zu suchen hat, aber,
was auch öffentlich gemacht werden sollte oder zumindest öffentlich gemacht werden äh öffentlich diskutiert werden sollte,
Damit es einfach diesen Nimbus, das du darfst nicht darüber reden, verliert. Das, denke ich mal, war jetzt primäre Intention. Das ist einfach, das sind genau die interessanten Gedanken und ich bin auch ganz bei dir, wenn du sagst, für dich ist das eher so eine philosophische,
Äh Debatte, die dort geführt werden wird oder werden sollte, ja, als jetzt so eine aktivistische. Ja, das sehe ich da an der Stelle eigentlich genauso.
Und als solche äh sicherlich äh eine ganz interessante,
Sache im Prinzip sag ich mal ihre Datenbasis gibt es im Moment nicht her politische Forderungen abzuleiten, sagen wir mal so.
Insgesamt muss man dann, glaube ich, schon sein, dass diese Spaghelliarde für für viele eben enttäuschend war. Ähm,
weil also was nicht zuletzt auch dann, ich meine, am ersten Tag fallen zwei eindeutig interessante Vorträge aus. Ähm es gab da eine etwas traurige Situation, da,
Tante noch das die Abschlussfazit dann sprechen sollte und das.
Also des ersten Tages.
Ersten Tages und das äh da macht äh das macht er alles ein sehr weil er etwas unglücklich ja, weil weil er ihm da nicht so wirklich so ein Fazit äh gelang,
ähm aber insgesamt denke ich, dass das äh wie gesagt für Soziologen und gerade so in diesem Bereich,
echt spannende und Philosophen und so echt spannende äh Themen sind, die da besprochen werden. Also Jeff Jarves hatte ja dann, glaube ich, auch noch irgendwie so einen Skype-Vortrag gehalten, aber der erzählt ja auch seit Jahren nichts neues mehr. Also die Geschichte mit der Prostata kennen ja alle,
der sagte selbst der Spagheria-Publikum, dass da jetzt nichts Neues dabei wär. Ähm ich hatte den nicht gesehen,
Ähm aber so als also so philosophisch äh auf jeden Fall denke ich ein ganz interessantes äh Themenfeld.
Kommen wir zum Ende, Linus. Sonst noch irgendwas spannendes äh passiert?
Also es war jetzt im Prinzip war das ja jetzt alles nicht spannend, ne? Bis auf das mit den äh Kinder schlagen. Also da das hat jetzt die Grundsatzentscheidung. Kinder schlagen
oder Falschharing, ja. Das ist die, das ist die Frage der Zukunft. Ja, was ist das höhere Gut? Urheberrecht oder körperliche Unversehrtheit? Darauf läuft's am Ende hinaus
das ist der Kampf, den wir bekämpfen.
Hast du denn, ich habe das Video äh veröffentlicht hier äh von uns in Dresden. Hast du gesehen?
Habe ich gesehen, ja. Ich habe, ich habe nur den Anfang geguckt, der Anfang war gut.
Ja, der Anfang war ja auch das Special. Die Pre-Show.
Ja.
Ansonsten weiß ich da, wollte ich das nicht gucken, weil ich ja, wie gesagt, die ganze Zeit irgendwie ins in so eine Ecke geguckt habe bei der Aufnahme und also jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wie dieses Video äh ob man merkt, dass ich da die ganze Zeit eigentlich
irgendwie in die Ecke gucke. Jetzt merkt man's wahrscheinlich, weil ich gesagt habe, es ist ganz schlimm, ist ganz schlimm. Jetzt jetzt bitte nicht mehr gucken, weil sonst merken das alle, dass ich, dass ich.
Weiß gar nicht, was du hast. Ich fand das durchaus äh.
Dass ich irgendwie.
Außerdem guckst du doch hier auch immer die ganze Zeit in die Ecke. Oh Gott, das hätte ich jetzt nicht sagen dürfen.
Katatonisch.
Na ja, jeder hat so seine Stärken. Beim einen ist die Facebook-Fahndung.
Ich gucke nicht in die Ecke, ich stehe hier an meinem Pult und blicke in die Ferne.
Genau,
Ja. Linus, dann.
Würde ich sagen, machen wir hiermit äh Feierabend, oder?
Machen wir Schluss. Das war's. Tschüss. Danke fürs Zuhören.
Tschau, tschau.